so you got a flat tire on your moped
okay so the first thing I'm going to do
is take the rear brake cable off by
loosening this this bolt right here
there it goes it just pops right up now
I'm going to take the axle bolt off need
one wrench on the other side it's one
long bolt so you move the wrenches
opposite each other and then once
they're loose enough you can just do it
by hand you don't need to take them all
the way off just get them loose enough
so that the wheel slides these are the
tensioners you just flip them out of the
way and then you can give the wheel a
little tap forward at this point the
chain is really loose and you can just
derail the chain by moving to the side
and spinning the wheel until it pops off
okay so let the chain hang out of the
way and you can give the wheel a little
tap forward until it falls out of the
dropouts so now your wheel is off you
can choose to leave the bolts on or off
if they're getting in your way by
rattling around you can just take them
off take the parts off in order so you
remember how to put them back on when
you go to reassemble your wheel you have
the axle nut a washer chain tensioner
and the entire brake assembly and then
the other axle the other side of the
axle just slides out in one piece okay
the next thing I'm going to do is take
the valve cap off and a little bolt hold
it on and use my tire irons to take off
this tire so the way I like to do it is
you get one iron under the bead and flip
it over and then if you go to either
direction either side find the point
where it's just kind of hanging over the
rim and before it goes all the way down
and touches you can find this nice
little spot where you can grab it again
and you flip that over take it out and
try to put pressure down so the bead
doesn't just kind of fall back into the
rim you move over farther push the valve
through
your finger and get the tube out and
this tube is garbage taking YouTube and
there's going to be a washer and a bolt
and then a second bolt you leave the
washer in the first one on and you take
this one off these guys are going to
hang out inside the tire and this one is
going to be on the outside
any regular bike pump you have at home
is going to work fine give it a little
bit of air just enough so that it barely
holds its shape and this is what you're
going to want when you're installing the
tire so before you put it back on you
want to find out why did my tire go flat
you take the whole tire off and inspect
it for any nails or anything you could
have picked up and then make sure
there's no debris or anything in the rim
so most tires have an arrow on it it
says rotation so make sure you get that
correct with the rotation of your wheel
so you put the first half of the bead on
and the bead is this part of the tire
it's actually filled with like a coiled
wined of metal or Kevlar or something
like that and then the way I like to do
this is you just put the the partially
inflated tube just kind of shove it in
there and then first thing you do is put
the valve in and try it you just got to
kind of find the hole that the valve is
going to go into that goes and the bolt
that came off with it originally the way
I like to do it is I start opposite the
valve and you can just start making sure
that when you're flipping the bead over
the rim just make sure you're not
pinching the tube anywhere because
that's the only that's the way you're
going to pop it so keep flipping it over
work it towards the valve you want the
valve to be the last part of the bead
that you're going to flip over so when
you get to a point when you you can't
you're not strong enough to keep
flipping this thing over the rim then
you take your tire iron out and what I
like to do is hold the tire away from
the rim with my fingers from the other
side and when I put the iron on the rim
get your fingers in there and make sure
you're not pinching the tube with the
iron
and then go ahead and flip it over and
then don't just rip it out after you've
gone in there you want to make sure that
you can come out without pinching the
tube really crucial and there you go
it's on we also want to make sure that
your tire is seated all the way around
you can see the edge of the bead on the
inside of the rim and if there's any
spaces where you can clearly tell that
it's kind of it's sucked in to the
inside of the rim then your tire has not
been seated and you need to deflate it
and re-inflate it until it seats itself
and this looks fine so I'm going to go
ahead and start putting things back
together the brake assembly has a slot
right here and it usually lines up with
a bolt that's sticking out of the inside
of the swingarm so that it's locked in
and it can't spin around you want to
make sure when you're installing the
wheel that you put it in the correct
location because if you miss if you
missed a little bolt and you hit the
brakes this thing is just going to spin
around with your wheel and it's going to
ruin it so make sure you get this slot
lined up from axle brake assembly and
adjuster and washer and the nut put
these on loosely so you have enough room
to get it into the rim take your chain
and rail it and then put your chain
tensioner back on with the little nub
facing outwards it's the way it works is
actually you can see it gets bigger and
then it slides the wheel forward and
back to wash them same thing on the
other side you have the same three
pieces again and now you can use these
chain tensioners to actually move the
wheel you can see that it rotates when I
adjust it and what you want is you want
to have the wheel straight with the bike
and at the same time you want to have
the perfect tension on the chain the
chain wants to have about a half inch to
an inch of plate so that feels about
right to me and then you have to make
sure your wheel straight so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to tension I'm
going to tension one and loosen the
other and that will bring the wheel over
and you do those at the same time and
you do it properly you can move the
wheel over and keep the tension at the
proper amount which is
after one inch right so I feel like I'm
pretty centered here so I'm going to go
ahead and tighten down the axle bolts
all right looks good to me
the last thing you want to do before you
ride off is don't forget that we did
take off the rear brake cable so install
that and the way I like to do this is
get the bolt ready to be tightened but
still loose enough so that the cable
will slide in that squeeze the assembly
shut with your fingers and then let off
a quarter of an inch and then go ahead
and tighten and then you have a small
adjuster here and there's usually an
adjuster up at your handlebar level and
you can fine tune where you like your
brakes if you like to be able to squeeze
them a lot before they engage or just a
little bit so just double-check and make
sure that it's the way you like it
feels fine to me there you go change
your tire
you